it's going pretty bad
with the coral reefs in the wild
among other things due to climate change
but also overfishing or pollution
coral reefs are very important ecosystems
they have 1 very large biodiversity
and that's why it's so important
to save this coral reef
and through this project we can
Save 1 piece of coral reef
so we have received 14 types of coral
that is now Large enough
to be able to expand in our reef
so we have released 2 types of them today
the acropora
it is 1 acropora species and 1 gardiener rosérus
one is 1 bit branched acropora type
it actually grows as 1 kind of antler
as branches and those wardrobe series
that is something that grows more than 1 spherical coral
world kirkels victory project
is 1 international project
where we keep several public aquariums corals
and these corals have 1 known origin
and that gives them
the potential to be turned off again
in the wild
I am also quite proud that we are that kind
all alive
have been able to keep
I just think it's special
to work with those corals
they grow very slowly
they are actually
in terms of loving animals,
they are 1 bit complicated
that challenges me SAY in my work
so that way I always find it very interesting
to work on such projects
maybe 1 of the nicest things about my job
I think it's very important to be with it
project to cooperate
I think it is important to contribute 1 bit
to the conservation of nature and the protection of
these important ecosystems